leave motivation what's the top 10 with
believe nation hates Evan Carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back a lack of belief in
yourself you watch these videos because
you know there's something more inside
you you've got Michael Jordan level
talent at something so get ready to be
different go big and not rely on
business plans with Dan Pena and my take
on his top ten roses success volume 10
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
1 be different difference between a
victim and victory is action most of you
and most of the people on the youtubes
have led quiet eyes of desperation and
they live their lives as victims just as
your parents have and just cuz your
parents or a doctor or a lawyer or
doesn't make it you know that's an
honorable profession I'm not discounted
I mean being a schoolteacher is an
honorable profession being a plumber is
an honorable profession
you wanna you want to create
generational wealth change the lives of
a billion people
none of your ideas in this room or
changing lives of a million people let
alone 1 billion Zuckerberg is the most
recent example of that God knows he's
changed the lives of three and a half
billion I'm not so sure for the best but
that's a whole other story but I mean
you know if you're not first we've got
to be different your ideas what's your
unique selling proposition what's the
barrier to entry all these things that
you know when I look at your new deals
and I'm not even counting the deals
these [ __ ] on YouTube said yeah I've
forget about that but I mean you has
anybody ever thought this through
and the courses in the podcasts and the
web doesn't anybody ever talk about
Barry to aintry if you're not first we
got to be different does anybody talk
about that know me but you go big it
doesn't register that you can make ten
million dollars in a day I remember the
first day I made $10,000 October the
fifth 1974 I remember the first day I
made a hundred thousand dollars 1976 I
remember the first day I made a million
dollars to me okay I remember the first
day I made ten million dollars and I
remember like when I took a this morning
and brush my teeth the day I made a
hundred million pounds and one day me
without question your goals are too low
and they're too low why mommy and daddy
who probably had no goals you know my
dad my parents only had one goal in life
to keep me alive until I reach the age
of reason that's it
there wasn't any because I was a they
used to call a problem child back in
those days I don't you know but I was a
tear to say the least
rule number three don't rely on business
plans a pile of crap five six lines ago
and most of what you've learned today
about creating generational wealth being
an entrepreneur starting a business is
crap
I heard somebody say earlier about a
business plan business plans are passe
they're not needed I'll explain it later
why they're not meeting these are the
business plans it's a while ask yes I've
never seen in 50 years of doing this a
business plan fail on paper I'm gonna
say that again I've never seen a
business plan fail on paper
why because you put the most optimistic
in there right so who's gonna believe a
business plan only morons that's why
they're not needed rule number four play
to win if you started the business the
first 50,000 pounds euros or dollars in
your business was geometric growth
quantum leap the next 50 or 100 thousand
dollars or pounds or euros was geometric
growth then what happened
you started playing not to lose instead
of playing to win you sat on your assets
like a mother hen and we're afraid that
you're going to lose the money that you
made anybody that's gone from zero to a
hundred thousand zero to ten thousand
has created geometric growth some of you
saw it khunts in this room half which is
hard to believe shows goes to show any
person can do it even brain-dead retards
like you
the first dollar did you make euro pound
is geometric growth you retards
then why didn't you continue also if you
want to have more confidence in
self-love check out my 254 series
they're free the links Joyner in the
description below but no one guys know
initially upfront you have to try if the
swing at the plate a kid like you if you
had to keep track of seven days a week
24 hours a day what you do and you want
people with a like mind and that are
better than you smarter than you more
intelligent than you to get on your bus
rule number five use fear to your
advantage I know fear works and I'm a
proponent of it
and anybody thinks any different is
crazy bullish I don't know what the
right terminology here still works just
in athletics today you University of
Central Florida who won one of the
national championships in football last
year the fear of not making the team
they use to recruit because they're the
one of the two national champions and
the other whoever the other one was the
fear of getting cut from the team in
athletics the fear of not making the
Olympic team
not getting good enough grades to get
into Harvard where with a you know what
I go to school
but they they couch it differently now
they don't call it fear they call it
motivation but motivation to fear works
rule number six
find your true path well a young second
lieutenant and I going to the old club I
know they don't have office clubs
anymore but in those days they did I go
to the old club and everybody's drinking
and I said one before we go drinking
which is Dave and here it is $1,400,000
I never heard that before
I didn't know how many zeros was in a
minion I'm not lying so I said could you
write one big important thought about a
napkin for me you get I thought it was
rigged up right so again a few weeks
later I get an award and I'm being the
award there that's two-star general who
drove on retired three-star general West
Point guy and he said I got an award but
I came up with an idea to save the army
two million dollars by asking that came
up then they gave me a $50 more bar this
is how the minami today $50 the war
there were six thousand 75 cents when
they gave it to me I say too many
dollars they need $6.75 we report to
director one-star general doesn't West
Point kid so we're the old pub general
address on the side of eternal bonds on
the side hey I'm a first lieutenant by
this time and they said Danny you oughta
buy his drinks why is that well first of
all if you start Daniel cuz of your
first lieutenant you start buying your
max right and so I said but wise
attitude you won that bet award and I
still it's only one 6000 said if I sit
down again he said the magic words
Danny a young boy like you and the
civilian world would be rich and a light
bulb went off in my head I can still
remember the moment a light bulb
I was in to be a regular army officer I
like the military I love my head money
civilian like I was out of the Army in
six months six months and one week later
I'm out just talk a lot of people from a
five percenter young hard-charger you
probably got some of the guy a young
heart charters young junior officers
here at the Naval Academy saw him out
and six months in one week and the world
has been my host ever since rule number
seven love what you do every day I get
stronger every day in the seminar you
get weaker why do you think that is
because I love what I do and you hate
what you do there's a slide coming up
tomorrow Gallup poll in 2016
eighty-seven percent eighty seven point
seven percent of the people on the world
hate their lives 87 percent hate their
lives I'd like to find a 13 percent I
found too many of those but they say
they're around remember eight stop
giving tacit approval most of you have
lived your lives and your parents lives
giving tacit approval tacit approval is
the reason why you're here today and the
people that on YouTube are poor on
YouTube we casted approvals this this
guy tells me something and I know it's
horse I just didn't listen and then I'm
walk away right or god forbid and I hear
his Bush and I happen to nod my head
okay now he goes so there's other
muttonhead over here and he says Dan's
on board not because I said I was on
board or by accident nodded my head up
and down because I didn't say I wasn't
on board in his mind I've given him pass
it approval
you've lived your whole lives for those
of you that work in big organizations
you listen to your boss you know he's
foolish but you just sit there and
listen now I got in trouble I use and
you're polish that's [ __ ] all my
life and I told you dr. Shirley Teeter
said the only thing that's changed with
Danny Pena is that his accomplishments
have caught up with his big mouth rule
number nine don't show weaknesses the
thing that always amuses me is that the
current day movies and stuff they're at
the end of the movie normally today that
people reconcile that's not my
experience the higher performer the
higher the performance person the less
probability that they're going to
reconcile with anybody why because they
don't need anybody
and almost all the big hitters
you know in President Trump is a primary
example of this a preeminent example
saying sorry is a weakness
apologize
the weakness saying you were wrong was a
weakness what do I say I may be wrong
but I'm never in doubt every I know
which flies in the face of all the bush
now
president Trump doubles down triples
down I don't know if you can quadruple
down but and that's my experience with
those guys and the few really
high-powered women that I've known
so again it flies in the face of
virtually everything you've been taught
and you'll number 10 the last one before
a very special bonus clip is surround
yourself with success when I first read
Think and Grow Rich in 7 1972 I think I
underlined it and then I didn't read it
again till I believe in the early 80s
and I had the same copy of the
underlined and I went back and was
interesting when I underlined in 72 as
opposed to what I underlined in 82 and
then when I read it again in about 2003
for the things that I underlined the
first time I said why how come I didn't
understand that the person I mean that's
so simple and most of the stuff that I
underlined the second time is just it
was a slam dunk and so because I had
grown and matured not just because you
know the mayor of the frontal lobe of
the brought a male brain isn't finished
maturing or growing until you 26 27 or
28 the frontal lobe the frontal lobe of
the female brain is mature way before
that way before that and the and so when
I was even though I was pretty
successful in my mid-20s the mostly by
design some by serendipity but most of
my success was because I was around
successful people and I didn't
understand you you are who you hang
around with show me your friends and
I'll show you future I didn't know that
concept but I know now looking back a
lot of these guys I was not hanging with
but I mean I was exposing myself to
their business principles like bunker
hunt and and who was part of the
billionaire Hunt Brothers and it was
quite quite interesting now I have a
special bonus clip from Dan on how to go
for it that I think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the three
point landing questions let's go from
just watching the video to taking action
here we go question number one how can
you better surround yourself with
success number two where can you use
fear to your advantage
and number three how can you play bigger
and if you promise to take action after
watching this video we don't just watch
videos anymore we do something after
watching them give me a hashtag believe
down the comments make that promise to
yourself and then get to work
this is my natural personality I I lived
I'm living about 20,000 years too late
that's right when I should have it
[Music]
good-looking girl go by his club his or
her partner in the face cave in his head
and take it you know I got a business I
like Club you to death tape that my
natural personality I'm an alpha male
you got it already figured out but you
don't have to be an alpha male to be a
high performance person 90% of the
business leaders in the world are not
Aquaman's
pony 2% okay Bert had one thing at Tom
there introduce each of hurts
if you want more day in pain I checked
at the last top-10 I made the link is
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there you if you can't fail your
dream nobody's going to join you Oprah
Winfrey's got a saying about you know
it's it's not exactly important where
the bus is going